write down all the things you were going
to do to get to that Vision all the
choices you were going to make all of
the experiences or goals you wanted to
achieve and all of the emotions and the
joy you would feel and when you were
doing that you were setting your sights
towards that Destiny and then you did
something really brilliant you wrote
down the choices you weren't going to
make you became aware of the behaviors
you weren't going to demonstrate you
began to review certain experiences you
wanted to stay away from and then you
looked at the emotions that would bring
you to a lower level and you begin to
separate the old self from the new self
and when you begin to do that and you're
observing the old self it means you're
no longer the program now you're the
Consciousness observing the program and
that's when you begin to objectify your
subjective self hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because I need
it I need it for me because I don't wake
up every day and say yes let's go
conquer the world now I wake up and and
I need that external motivation to match
my internal motivation when I see
somebody who's doing amazing things it
makes me just want to play a bigger game
and so I hope that today's video makes
you want to play a bigger game too
because your message matters and let's
get it out to the world so today let's
learn how to write things down so the
universe can bring it to us with Dr Joe
dispenza enjoy
let's say you've had some pretty rough
experiences in your past
and those experiences cause you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental that
that's just feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say today
I'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about two hours
and then all of a sudden the moment you
realize that you're no longer making the
same choices as the day before you are
going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
is going to be uncertain there's going
to be some unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change rule number two is create more
balance I want you to know that you have
within your reach all the Machinery to
begin to connect to this field of
intelligence that we have access to
called the unified field you'll learn
how to organize your autonomic nervous
system and create more wholeness and
balance in your body you'll be able to
understand what it means to get Beyond
yourself and ultimately create a new
future
so think about this
if you spend the majority of your day
focusing on matter
focusing on everything in this
three-dimensional world that's made of
material things it begs the question how
much of your time and your attention do
you put on that unified field that
invisible field of information that
exists beyond space and time
and just like when you're unaware of
your nose it doesn't exist and the
moment you become aware of it it exists
the quantum field is exactly the same
way if you put very little attention on
it in your waking day then it doesn't
exist for you but the moment you begin
to become aware of it the moment you
begin to pay attention to it the moment
you begin to stay present with it and to
experience it moment after moment and if
where you place your attention as you
learned is where you place your energy
and where you place your attention
causes things to expand the moment you
begin to experience it not with your
senses you experience this
three-dimensional reality with your
senses but you experience it with your
Consciousness and with your awareness
the moment you become pure Consciousness
is the moment you make contact with that
unified field and so we now know
the techniques and the tools to get
people Beyond themselves and in fact we
know that after thousands and thousands
and thousands of brain scans that you're
at your absolute best when you get
Beyond yourself when you take your
attention off your body
when you take your attention off your
identity that's connected to people in
your life the things you own objects you
own places you have to go and time
itself the moment you become nobody no
one no thing no where in no time that is
the moment you become pure Consciousness
and that's the moment you begin to
connect to that field of possibilities
called the unified field or the quantum
field and that field in this invisible
field of information that exists Beyond
this space and time an independent of
the color of your skin your gender your
diet your sexual preference independent
of your profession your class
independent of all those things that
create separation
that every human being has access to it
and this
course is about not waiting for crisis
to begin to create the life you want but
in fact becoming inspired that you are
the creator of your life and using the
tools and principles to be able to do it
as an example we had a student who
wanted to prove to herself that she
could become an abundant person
and I want to remind you it's not about
the wealth that she was interested in it
was who she was becoming in the process
and every single day she got beyond the
thoughts that I can't it's too hard I'll
never be wealthy money is bad she got
beyond the habits of living in lack and
not being afraid to spend money and
taking a chance she got beyond the
emotions of unworthiness and and
separation
and fear and every single day she kept
creating and becoming something else
she parked her car and was heading to a
meeting and went to the meeting and when
she came out she took her ticket and was
going to pay for the time that she was
there and all of a sudden a hundred
dollar bills just started shooting out
of the machine now
she was so Overjoyed because she was
correlating that experience of money
flowing to her with the experience that
she had just had a few days before in
her meditation where she had connected
to that field and she felt it flowing
through her and when she saw the money
flying out of the machine hundred dollar
bills and everybody's standing around
looking at it it was no longer about the
money it was about the fact that she
created it and she left the money for
everybody else to have because that's
what abundant people do
and she continued and laughed all the
way home and realized that if she could
create that she could create anything
now Beauty behind that is that it could
happen to you and many experiences for
many of our students are pretty much the
same
so
the course is about you connecting to
that field that the course is about you
getting Beyond yourself
the instructions are for you to be begin
to create more inner balance so it can
be witnessed in your outer world and to
literally create a new future rule
number three is connect to your future
dream once again the signal that you're
creating
on a daily basis
is going to either work in a
constructive way or in a destructive way
and as an example if you're walking
around feeling sorry for yourself and
suffering and feeling victimized
then you're actually emanating that
signal into the field and what you're
saying is braming experience equal to my
suffering but bring it in a way that I
least expect that surprises me and
leaves no doubt that I've created this
outcome so in a sense we're not punished
for our sins we're punished by our sins
and sin is an attitude so then the
opposite is also true
when you teach people how to connect to
the energy of a future dream and be
defined by a vision of the future
instead of the memories of the past to
believe in their future more than they
believe in their past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you which also means then the moment you
get in your car and start getting angry
and getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less of less people are experiencing
the state of being called being a victim
so then if you're a victim then you
would say I was angry because of traffic
well then I would say to you well you
mean your outer world was controlling
how you think and feel some circumstance
some person something in your outer
world is actually controlling your
feelings and thoughts that means you're
a victim to those circumstances but when
you change the way you think and feel
and it starts to produce effects in your
outer world now you start to realize
you're the creator of your life and the
moment you start seeing feedback in your
life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is change your
personality our simple model is that
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality
is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this podcast has created the present
personal reality called it life which
means that if you want to change your
life you want to create a new person in
reality you're gonna have to change your
personality you're going to have to
change because nothing changes in your
life until you change so what is the
understanding of change that we've spent
over 10 years studying a way to explain
what change is because
if you think 60 to 70 000 thoughts or
however many thoughts in one day and
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before you're
in trouble because the same thoughts
will lead to the same choices the same
choices will lead to the same behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce those very same emotions and
those same emotions influence our same
thoughts and our biology our neural
circuitry our neurochemistry our
hormones our gene expression
our immune everything stays the same
because we're the same so it has
traditionally taken crisis or trauma or
loss for someone to make up their mind
to change so the moment we decide to
change okay I want to create a new
personal reality a new life
I got to change my personality well this
concept called metacognition we have
four brain function you know the seat of
our conscience our frontal lobe allows
us to think about what we're thinking
about to notice how we're behaving and
and to become aware of how we're feeling
and
the the repetition of thinking acting
and feeling in the same way causes our
brain to become hardwired into very
specific neural patterns right so that
that firing and wiring over time cause
us causes us to be happen so
automatically that we're unconscious
of our conscious self so the moment we
become conscious of those thoughts the
moment we become aware of those
behaviors the moments we notice those
feelings we're no longer the program in
fact where the Consciousness observing
the program and that's the first step to
change so when you decide
and become so conscious the word
meditation I looked it up
the symbol means to become familiar with
that's all it means it means
familiarization so if you become so
familiar with I can it's too hard I'll
never change no one loves me you become
aware that you are blaming complaining
you all all day long and talking trash
about somebody you notice all of a
sudden that this feeling that you're
feeling every single day that you're so
accustomed to is really guilt or shame
or unworthiness the moment you're
conscious of what what you're
experiencing in other words when you're
inside the jar you can't read the label
right so you gotta become conscious of
that unconscious stuff you got to see
yourself Through The Eyes of someone
else the tragedy that causes you to no
longer feel like you any longer actually
causes you to look at you from the eyes
of someone else you can see yourself
more clearly because you're not feeling
like you any longer that's the
that's the big moment of change so then
when a person really can become so
conscious of their unconscious self that
they don't go unconscious again or let
me say it another way how many times do
we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
rule number five is recondition your
body how do you create the life you want
and how do you begin to have you know
your subjective mind produce effects in
your objective world now the quantum
model says that the moment you begin to
look for an electron electron you know
is in a field of probabilities or
possibilities and the Observer comes
along and the observer looks and all of
a sudden Boom the electron appears it
collapses from a wave of possibilities
into an event called collapsing the wave
function that's a Quantum event so mind
and matter are somehow correlated so the
question is can you observe
your life the way you want and cause
infinite patterns of energy to collapse
into new information called the new
experience in your life or a new Quantum
event
so for two years we taught the workshops
around the world and guess what happened
not a lot we didn't see a lot of change
every now and then we see people's lives
were getting better here and there but
what I was after was because when I
wrote what the bleep I understood the
science of changing your mind the
process of change requires unlearning
and relearning
it requires breaking the habit of your
old self and then Reinventing a new self
it's what we say in Neuroscience pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections
unmerizing emotions that are stored in
your body and then reconditioning your
body to a new mind into a new emotion to
deprogram to reprogram to lose your mind
and create a new one
to move your energy out of the past and
then use that energy to drive you to a
new future
and so I saw what people did when they
had spontaneous remissions I saw
four things that they had in common all
of them believe that there was a
spiritual aspect to them something
greater that was giving them life that
they wanted to connect to they wanted to
give that intelligence a plan a template
a design and then surrender it and allow
it to do it for them
and so I began to realize that many many
people in the world were beginning to
embrace this concept of quantum physics
and spirituality the second thing they
had in common is they all understood it
was their mismanagement of their life
that created their disease it was their
20 years of hatred their 30 years of
bitterness through 10 years of guilt
they're 45 years of anger and those
emotions they had memorized and those
emotions were driving certain thoughts
and those thoughts were reaffirming
certain emotions and how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
thoughts are the language of the brain
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates a
state of being but the redundancy of
that cycle of thinking and feeling over
time conditions your body to memorize
that emotional state as well as the
conscious mind and moment the body knows
better than the mind that's called a
habit a habit is when your body is your
mind and 95 percent of Who We Are by the
time we're 35 years old this is science
it's a set of memorized behaviors
emotional reactions beliefs and
perceptions that function like an
unconscious subconscious automatic
program so when people go to change
they're using five percent of their
conscious mind to work against 95
percent of what they've memorized and
they would think positively all they
wanted but they've been memorizing
negativity for the last 25 years where
they create their dream board you know
with their SUV and their hairstyle and
kid in the back and you know fingernails
and house and but they felt unworthy
it's mind and body and opposition
and so I realized that the very emotions
of anger and aggression and hostility
and hatred and frustration and judgment
and fear and anxiety and hopelessness
and powerlessness and depression and
insecurity are all driven by the
hormones of stress and rule number six
the last time before some very special
bonus Clips is be the mind we found out
that when people react emotionally with
anger with antagonism
there's an arousal that takes place
because they're turning on the
sympathetic nervous system and the
sympathetic nervous systems and
primitive system saying Alex whatever
that whatever that is is a threat to you
and if there's a threat a good way to
deal with a threat is to get aggressive
that's primitive it's animal it's very
animal some people will say oh my God
there's my ex and instead of getting
angry they run
they flee they're in fear they're like
the fear is I'm better just getting away
so they they Their Fear causes them to
run uh uh so uh when people feel fear
when they feel anger when they feel pain
those are the primary stimulators that
switch on that sympathetic nervous
system and they used to stay
that it's automatic like it's automatic
it happens automatically that's part of
the autonomic nervous system and you
really don't have any control of it
turns out that's absolutely not the
truth so first thing
is learning how to shorten your response
to the emotional reaction so if you have
an event that happens to your life in in
your life and I say Alex why are you so
mad today and you say oh it's because of
this situation and this person this
happened this way and I would say oh my
gosh all right do you mean
that that person or that circumstance is
controlling the way you feel and the way
you think
now anything that's controlling the way
we feel in the way we think makes us
victims
whatever that is now that's okay but if
you keep that emotional reaction going
on
for hours or days and I say to you Alex
it's five days what's up and you say to
me I'm I'm upset from something that
happened to me five days ago I'd say you
have a mood you're in a mood now some
people
keep that same emotional reaction going
on
for weeks or months and then I would say
well Alex has a angry temperament it
becomes a temperament if we keep it
going for now this is true people keep
this going for years on end
if it goes on for years now it's a
personality trait so here's the weird
part about it
you ask that person who's been angry for
years why they're angry
and they'll recall an event from 10
years ago or a series of events from 10
years ago
yeah and the research on the memory says
that 50 of that story isn't even the
truth that they can't even remember the
truth they embellish the story and make
it sound worse than it really was to
excuse themselves from changing now
what we tell people is
forget the event
doesn't matter the details of the event
doesn't what matters
is learning how to overcome the emotion
so when you're sitting in a meditation
and all of a sudden out of nowhere your
body starts getting aroused and it
starts getting frustrated and it starts
getting angry and people say I'm doing
my meditation wrong you know what I say
to them no no no no you're doing it
right because that has to come up so
then
so when the anger and the frustration
comes up and a person's in a meditation
they have one of two choices to quit
which is what they've always done
but if you're sitting with 1500 people
and no one else is quitting you're not
going to quit
and if I teach you how to lower the
volume to that emotion and I teach you a
way to change that
every time you settle the body back down
into the present moment and lower the
volume to that anger
that's a victory because you're telling
the body it's no longer the mind that
you're the mind now it'll go well yeah
well what about this circumstance and
what about that and it'll get aroused
again
and then you notice it and instead of
turning on the TV or getting on your
cell phone or getting on the social
media
you lower the volume again now this is
the work
it turns out every time you do that that
Victory you're telling the body that
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and then all of a sudden wants to
get up and go it's busy it's got things
to do and it's and and you become aware
that it wants to do that and you bring
it back to the present moment you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program now
turns out if you do this enough times
sooner or later the body surrenders
sooner the later the body acquiesces it
says I'm no longer the mind
Alex is the mind and when that occurs
there's a liberation of energy that
anger
that frustration literally turns into
energy it's released into the field as
information now you return back into
your life and you see the same person or
the same circumstance your response to
them is going to be much less why
because you took care of it within you
you're not trying to fix it out there
it's just that your response is
different so now if you're no longer
responding to the environment and your
response to the environment isn't
weakening the organism because stress
depletes energy
then you're less susceptible to the
environment and we found out that when
people do this their immune system gets
so robust
that you can take viruses like SARS cov2
virus and subject that virus to the
plasma of advanced meditators and
there's a resistance to the right the
virus doesn't enter the cell why because
there's energy
for there's energy to be able to combat
it so so it's because the person is not
reacting so then shortening your
response
to that condition is a victory and it
takes practice and so then how many
times
do we have to forget and go unconscious
and be angry till we decide to no longer
forget and keep remembering and stay
conscious that's change right there so
we use meditation as a model to remind
ourselves who we're going to be when we
open our eyes and to remind ourselves
who are no longer going to be when we
open our eyes and stay so conscious of
it that we don't go unconscious in our
waking day and if we do it properly
then there's feedback in our life that
shows us that you've changed and
remember nothing changes
in your life until you change
and I hear this from so many people
Gabby I'm I'm doing it all I'm
meditating I'm praying I'm setting
intentions creating vision boards but
I'm not manifesting one reason you're
not manifesting is because you don't
believe in what you're trying to
manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy and so you have to do
your part to get into the belief system
of knowing that this is indeed something
you are worthy of so how do you get into
that grounded belief system create a
vision statement a statement that claims
that your desire is on the way that you
are worthy of what it is that you desire
ground yourself in that statement focus
on it and instead of focusing on the
outcome focus on the feeling of what it
is to believe and know that you are
worthy of your desire if you're wanting
to attract a romantic partner into your
life a vision statement could sound like
I believe I'm worthy of the love that I
desire where I believe that I am ready
to receive that romantic relationship in
the perfect time in order say that
vision statement daily for at least 40
days get yourself grounded in the belief
you have to believe it to receive it the
next reason you're not manifesting
because you're trying too hard
I'm sorry to say it but it's true the
more you push the more you control the
more you try the more you affirm the
more you vision board the more the more
the more the less you receive if you're
pushing and you're controlling and
you're trying to make something happen
if you are completely out of alignment
with the universe you're not aligned
with that freedom that presence of Love
The Art of allowing rather than doing
forcing making happen yeah we have to
show up for our life but we can't force
our dreams to become a reality so the
key here is to let go so here's your
message the secret to manifesting is to
forget what you think you need let it go
how do you let it go with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
wait what do you mean well what I mean
is that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging a lot you're focusing on
scary things that make you so anxious
and you just keep focusing on them and
dwelling on them you're obsessed with
worrying you love to overthink things
look I understand that behavior more
than anyone could imagine I'm a
recovering Warrior I'm a recovering
anxious person I've been there I
understand that but when we are not in
that vibration that's relaxed released
at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff lean into the positive
look for Solutions rather than problems
stop yourself when you notice that
you're being judgmental or gossipy hang
out with people that make you feel good
do things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracting what you desire just relax
it's all good focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally we have the power
within us to attract what we desire when
we allow our internal condition to
reflect what we want to attract on the
outside so make that your highest
priority see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone there
isn't anyone that cannot live the way
they want to live
see
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something really want then they back
away
where they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs and they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we have the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting X-Type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from Left
Field above bone in comes a y-type idea
what is the y-type idea the y-type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
yet might be moved to another city
change jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the Y idea is just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen
well that's when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some strange reason they
know that they've got to get emotionally
involved if they're going to act on that
idea they don't understand what's going
to happen but clearly understand this
your central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an extra XY vibration it's
not in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable
no on a conscious level everything's
going crazy on a conscious level we
experience doubt that doubt turns into
an emotion called fear and that fear is
expressed through the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier see the terror barrier is going
Beyond where you're at going to a new
level I'm going to tell you something
when I set a goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead
I don't want to live there
I used to lived there for the first 26
years of my life and for the last 50
I've had a phenomenal life and it just
keeps getting better and I want you to
do the same thing understand what I've
just said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
their experiencing some crazy stuff they
start to doubt their ability we'll never
be able to pay for it they experience
fear the fear expresses itself as
anxiety
and bang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
that's energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel a sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek what you believe about
yourself is the only thing that matters
at the end of the day no matter how much
outside affirmations you get or other
people telling you that you're amazing
if you don't believe in your heart that
you are amazing it won't none of that
will last like you've ever gone to an
event or you ever made a video or
created something or you're hanging out
with a friend and they tell you how
amazing you are and that feels good
right like the external affirmations and
validation feels great but then it fades
but that stuff doesn't last you don't
have somebody being a cheerleader for
you every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that you have to be
that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never going to love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
well okay so that's that's a lot of
words how do you actually go off and do
it
like for me it's this is why I believe
that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
barely hanging on to what we're doing we
we can post all these great things on
Instagram or wherever and make it look
like we're enjoying our life but most
people are barely hanging on the people
who are judging you for your life and
telling you that you suck hate their own
lives they are barely hanging on so how
do we get through it well yes we can be
harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
um I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masculine
and insecurity right it's like those
people who uh have you ever seen those
memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything and I was like doesn't care
you know just walking on a T-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masculine
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if it came on you would have to you
would have to move right it doesn't mean
that you're up and like dancing through
the whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from feeling low
and tired and just what what day is it
what am I doing I wake up every day like
what day is it what am I doing today
yeah it's but I demand excellence and
that that starts with music because I
don't have I don't want to spend a lot
of time trying to get into the right
state of mind I can command it whenever
I want just by putting on the right song
so be in tension with your music and the
lyrics being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rucking a walk
to Tim Hortons usually get a coffee you
know this costs two bucks two something
so I only had now what's the what's the
best money I spend every year well it's
the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
a coffee every morning and I'm thinking
about what's my intention for the day
and I'm thinking about what I want to
accomplish today and the lives that I
want to serve and the people I want to
help and and what I'm about to do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brandytics I'll start at 10
30. and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate I mean
it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe walks
do those two things put on a playlist
put on music every morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters is how
you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation in somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things could you speak
about the neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no and the more we
remember the event the more we produce
the emotions that are associated with it
and we're conditioning the brain and
body further into the past yes or no and
it you keep doing it enough times it's
no longer conscious that you're holding
a grudge
it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this we
all do it
it's just how do we overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding is nobody no one no
thing nowhere and no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
which energy is going to move it's got
to it's going to follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold a grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still
so then from a Quantum perspective you
are actually as a creator of reality
holding yourself hostage because of that
person
and you were holding them hostage
because of that experience and you have
an energetic Bond that's connecting you
to them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and I let them
go
so then forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them that's
all it is and when you start getting
happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes its here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation
and oxytocin then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work and
then you forgive and then you're like I
don't want to forgive him
[Music]
halfway forgive them
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
and when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same life
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day
a man took a walk he went for a long
walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired so he thought oh I'm tired I wish
I could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested but I'm feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him you need to understand
they have the services like that
[Music]
hungry people don't ask questions
food came and he ate
stomach became full then he thought oh
my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
your monkeys your tail fell away not me
Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's
unnecessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is
if I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and Ghost came
oh the ghosts have come they're going to
surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghost
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of some yukti
is referred to as a cultivation
foreign
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction once all these four dimensions
of you your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's a source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverence is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive for what
you want
[Music]
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want the guide to a fulfilling life with
Joe dispenza check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you begin to create from the
field
instead of from matter the only way you
can do that is you have to learn how to
take all of your attention off your body
and become a nobody
take all of your attention